hello everybody welcome to another
episode of riffing with Griffin thank
you for staying with me on the journey
and as usual guys I am still looking for
a theme song and I'm so glad you guys
are here on the ride as we try to figure
out what's best for riffing with Griffin
but who knows this just might be the one
so ladies and gentlemen take take a seat
and get comfortable because Eric Griffin
is here and we're gonna be riffing and
this just might be the one we want we're
no strangers to podcast you know the
rules and sub a full commitment to
telling it like it is you wouldn't get
this from any other guy
[Music]
just wanna tell you I'm feeling gonna
make you understand this ripping wait
Griffin Griffin whip whipping written
weekly have been hurt you never gonna
tell the lie this week we have them
won't desert you there it is y'all
another ridiculous intro for a riff and
with Griffin that might be the one dough
we'll see I thought you got some really
great ones and the last episode was a
good one Lamont Landers and we're gonna
have a good one on in the next episode
you'll joy that my special new year's
episode but today hello everybody
you know today I want to talk about and
address the Kevin Hart issue and
internet trolls and sensitivity and and
how we don't have any more nuance in the
world right now and I think that's
what's missing right now is that you
know there's no nuance there's no
there's no really looking at a subject
and being like hey what are all the
factors what's the gray area here
everything's just so black and white my
first let's address internet trolls
because hey guess what I am added
internet trolls I get what they're doing
I mean comedians or society trolls
that's what we are I mean for comedians
to be mad at internet trolls it's just
that there's just no technique there's
no there's no like there's no skill when
somebody just goes on the internet we're
like a you know some weird name you know
squirrel rabbit 72 and they just write
some [ __ ] talk [ __ ] without any
panache and it's not even it's usually
not even funny it's usually just like
some [ __ ] I'm just like okay um this
I'm like okay get rid of this person but
I ain't mad at them
I'm not hyping them up either I'm not
hyping up trolls I'm just saying you
know yes it's put some effort into it
put some work that's what comedians do
comedians we write material we go work
it out then we do it on TV or even when
we're doing it in the clubs if it's like
a big show we're doing we've worked this
material out and now we're trolling
Society so I get it but it's not
necessarily the trolls did bother me
it's how we react to the trolls that to
me is the main problem so somebody comes
somebody comes up with something in
there like oh this hurt my feelings and
then now of a sudden we're supposed to
crucify the other person we're supposed
to be like well that person needs to be
removed from society we take away
context we take away what are the
circumstances of why this was said or
where was it said we forget about all
that we just look at these words and
that somebody put out there like this
person said this and then and then we
just have to take that at face value you
know I don't I don't subscribe to that I
think that that's what the problem is
right there so how we deal with internet
trolls it's a problem so I just want to
address this Kevin Hart issue I thought
Kevin Hart handled this great you know
he had something he had a people call it
home I guess it is homophobic in a sense
of how he was talking about it you know
he had this joke about if he saw his son
playing with a doll a doll and a
dollhouse he was smashed a dollhouse
over it over his head say stop you being
gay you know I'm paraphrasing the joke
but you know so if you'd read just that
if you hear just that if you see just
that you in your gay or in error and you
might take offense but in the whole
grand scheme of the context of like oh
if you hear that oh this a comedian and
it was at a comedy show and it was in a
context of another story if it was like
also and it's all how you interpreted -
because to me if you're comedian and you
say something like that
you're actually exposing how dumb you
are to feel that way that's why you're
saying it you know you're saying I feel
this way in your excuse you're being
vulnerable and you're putting your
thoughts out there like look I would
feel this way you know and this was back
in 2011 and in Kevin Hart has addressed
it over and over again he's already
addressed it he apologized for it even
if he only knew that he needed to
apologize for what he what you're saying
in a comedy routine you know but okay
people's feelings get hurt and then he
addressed it addressed it and then now
somebody is you know doing back research
on people's tweets just to like gotcha
oh look what you said in 140 characters
or look look what you said here look
what you did on your you're a special
you said this thing you insulted a bunch
of people and now we want you to
apologize before you get your next job
he already addressed it he already
talked about it at nauseam and now he's
moved on
he's a different person he doesn't even
do jokes like that anymore and he's just
trying to like do his thing and the
Academy is like look we want you to
apologize if you over get somebody else
the Kevin Hart was like bye see you and
I love that it says Oh first of all it
says a lot about the Academy Awards it's
there's a lot like the Academy Awards
needs to slow their roll they actually
think that that's an important thing
it's like a prestigious thing that it
used to be when the show was getting on
a bunch of press when the show was like
you know it was getting a lot heavy
ratings and everybody was watching it
and we believed you know that system of
like critics and these people who voting
sink telling us that these movies are
the best movies now it's different the
world's different I could care less what
critics say you can go [ __ ] yourself
critics I rather look on you know the
rotten tomato or whatever and you see
the critics and then you see what people
are saying and then you just go there's
more information out there now you
actually can go you know you can you can
tweet about it and be like yo what it
like a hundred people think of this
movie and you can decide based off that
stuff I mean before back in the day you
had to trust this going Ebert you had to
trust like you know the one critic from
the Los Angeles Times and the one guy
from the New York Post and the
Washington you know and then you would
take them on face value that was their
job to critique and be subjective about
something and you'd be like okay I think
I trust that guy so I'm gonna go see the
movie those days are gone
so therefore who cares what the Oscars
are who cares you know like that's
basically what's happening right now and
then the awards show itself has just
becoming so political you know we just
got these people it's just it's just
liberal Hollywood Hollywood elite man
you know they just look down on people
they forget that the middle of the
country a lot of these people for
instance voted for Trump so you don't
think they like movies so they're gonna
turn on the movie thing and then you're
gonna hear these liberal [ __ ] just you
know trashing and doing all these
political jokes and then these people
are at home like yeah I voted for that
guy and they're gonna change the channel
like so I don't know if that's the
platform for that I'm not a fan of it
I'm not a fan of protest about it am i
special I'm not a fan of protesting
you know at award shows this is let's
just celebrate to people that are here
you know what I mean let's celebrate
what they're doing and we and there's
other there's other time and place to be
you know why don't they just kneel then
to like you know what I mean um so to me
this is showing like like Kevin Hart's
letting him know like yo I'm a 40
million dollars from Netflix like this
is I'm fine
you know what I mean like I got a lot of
fans he travels all over the world he's
you know he's loved by his fans he don't
need that it would have been nice
feather in his cap because it's like one
of those things were you like you know
it's like one of those like notches like
oh I did that but it's not one that you
need so I think that was a mistake of
them to ask him to apologize like
because my point is this if they're so
worried about what a small faction of
society thinks then why aren't they
worried about what millions of Middle
America think about what people are
saying on these award shows like I'm not
a fan I'm not I'm not conservative I'm
not I'm not conservative politically
conservative I'm not I you know I'm not
gonna I don't want to talk politics but
I'm just saying there to me there are
more people who say voted for Trump for
instance that's a large population of
people you're not worried about
alienating them at your movie awards
show but you're worried about some
people that trolled Kevin Hart and
brought up something that he has already
apologized for already handled and you
want to fire him over that I it baffles
the mind and then something I really
thought is interesting is that you know
just two three years ago we were hash
tagging Oscars to white like this was
just a thing like they act like they're
on the high road now you still got some
work to do you know it was a man that's
why I don't like protesting because then
it takes away from when things actually
win you know it's like isn't you know
they had two Oscars too white and then
the next year the gay black movie wins
moonlight right it's like coincidence
and that sucks because moonlight was
fantastic movie and you know it probably
would have won anyway right but then
because of all that talk you there's a
moment of like ah I'm wonderful one
because of that so it takes away from it
so I don't like that but anyway my point
is the Oscars aren't as prestigious as
they think they are and I think that
they're I think they have misguided
about what they're upset about you know
you you still have a community of people
that think you're racist okay and so
then what you want to do is you don't
want to stick up for the guy that has
already apologized for this like you
already wanted him to do it and you want
him to do it why because he's rich and
famous because a lot of people know him
he's really funny he's really talented
and he's got a huge fan base right and
so that same thing is the reason you're
gonna hold against him now so then you
have this faction of people who like I
said are going back looking at tweets
and going back and look at the stuff
that happened ten years ago and then
want to judge this guy based off that
and then you and the Oscars want to go
yeah we agree with them so we're gonna
fire you it's like damn it's crazy and
so like I say I think Kevin art handled
it and you if you go to his Instagram
he's got a great video of saying I'm
paraphrasing like he just you know if I
have the thing right here I mean look at
it
he said I've made the choice to step
down from hosting this year's Oscars
what else did he say I sincerely
apologize to be community for my
insensitive words I mean he said that
like before you know he said that's so
so long ago you know that was what he
that's what he'd have before and so he
says I'm not going to continue to go
back and tap into the days of old when I
moved on and in a completely different
place and so he's like now this is he's
taking a stand he's making he's having
his own principles and I agree with him
so my question is this now so like do
these 140 characters like when like that
one basketball player who he won the
championship for Villanova and I think
he plays in Utah now if I cut his name
white boy red hair and he you know he
had some old tweets when he was 14 like
using the n-word and
in quoting a rap song you know and then
you know he just won a championship but
now these people want to go be get let's
go find him so my thing is like oh you
will do you really care about the issue
do you really care about insensitivity
or is this just just about gotcha like
do you really care like when trolls come
up with things and the whole country
just gets behind a subject they get
behind something and they go oh is this
what we really care about and then when
when we stop talking about it does that
subject go away does the insensitivity
go away no yeah so I don't know what
they're doing if I don't know what their
intentions are so you know some some kid
said something you know ten years ago or
said someone when they were 14 and we're
gonna hold them accountable for the rest
of their life yes words have power you
know words hurt you know people say
things and you know someday you can take
offense and sometimes you just you
apologize for that and then we move on
but the way we're doing it now it's like
somebody system that you don't like and
then you know you're like we have to cut
their head off they after their careers
should be over we have to remove them
from society and then what what was the
point of that you know what was the
point I think that like I just think
that the Oscars should have stepped up
and been like we stand behind Kevin Hart
he's already apologized for this it
doesn't it's not indicative of who he is
right now
and we're fine with it what they've done
is they've given these people power and
they've also get you know they've given
credit to this idea that he is this
person and I think that they take it
should've taken a moment it'd been like
no this is the overreaction and we're
moving on from it but you know
especially if they're not gonna move on
from all the other issues that they have
but anyways does 140 characters dictate
your character you know because I don't
even talk about how Twitter is now
people are looking back when it was only
140 characters I just think that when it
comes to comedy and specifically
comedians you know community has push
the envelope you know we say a lot of
inappropriate things and if someone is
hurt by that okay let's discuss it but
at the same time as you're saying to me
hey your words hurt I would like you to
also to acknowledge that a
that's not what you meant to do oh
you're oh you're doing comedy right now
oh that was at a comedy club oh that was
in the middle of a comedy set so there's
some context and there's some like a
time and place situation going on right
now
you know if you can acknowledge that too
I think that we'd be in a better place
but like just to like look at somebody's
Twitter and just be like man now that
guy is a bad person because he said
something eight years ago
or even worse like when you say oh that
guy said something when he was 16 so now
that he's a grown-ass man we have to
hold him accountable like that's who he
is what happened to second chances the
problem in our country is when we give
people second champion chances after
we've like taken away their first like
like we want to be the cause to take
people down and then go okay now we're
gonna grant you a second chance I mean I
just I don't get it we get mad about
things and then like to like the
sensitive intellectuals they want to
give you all these like intellectual
reasons especially when it comes to
comedy they want to be like well you
don't really know what this really
stands for okay obviously but that's why
I'm making a joke about the superficial
part of it if you don't see that then
what are we talking about you know that
I just like when Kendall Jenner
commercial the Pepsi commercial she
walks up to this to soldier and
everybody was up in arms about that to
me I was like okay so this hot model is
gonna bring a Pepsi to a soldier and
they're not gonna fight I think
what's wrong with that like hey it's all
perspective I have my own way of looking
at it I think we should just be like
okay I see what they're trying to do hey
guys it didn't work and we move on no
people want like we need to remove Pepsi
from you know from society because they
made this choice I mean people make
mistakes it's not even a mistake so much
as people just make a bad choice you
know a bad creative choice is really
what it is when it comes to the arts
like a comedian like just sometimes you
just make a bad choice I mean I get
people tweeting at me all the time about
stuff some of these tweets are just like
what like there was this heckler at the
at this club and she you know I don't
know what I don't even remember what
happened but just the other day I got
like four tweets from this lady and
she's telling me off you know
you know Erica Vinnie is not funny at
all and he needs to do this and then she
was trying to be sarcastic or whatever
and I read it to myself when I was like
oh what she probably feels great now she
put that out into the ether you know she
told me off and so now here I am you
know Here I am you know how do I take it
I could be like well [ __ ] this [ __ ] and
then like you know I go after her no I
just like okay cool I hope you feel
better cuz I don't give a you know I
mean like you were loud at the club you
were inappropriate I was making fun of
you it was great for the show we move on
from it right but we're not moving on
that's the thing that's happening right
now we just refuse to move on and when
with the internet kind of like what do
you call it documenting everything that
we say like everything's documented like
we're and we're put and we're doing it
ourselves well keeping it in our Twitter
Instagram snapchat database we're just
keeping all this information our little
thoughts good or bad that we're leaving
them there and then people can come back
and be like yo remember when you said
this I almost wish Twitter would do a
thing where they delete tweets you know
like after six months you you know
delete my history and let's move on from
there cuz you know I'm different now
boom I want to clear that out cuz like I
have and I know I've tweeted some stuff
like sometimes Twitter's just like a you
you say like whatever you're you feeling
something you like I can't believe that
happen you gonna boom boom and then like
people are holding you to that it's one
moment it's like it's like 20 seconds of
brain farting and people are judging
your character on it now yes words have
power look if you say something
completely egregious yeah you should
come and be like yo I apologize sorry
about that I didn't realize you felt
that way
whatever your apology is gonna be and
then also I would like the other person
to be like okay thank you and you know I
understand that you didn't think you
were hurting anybody by saying that I
think there there should be that should
happen on both sides you know and when
it doesn't happen to me
like what was the point of this then you
brought this up because you were hurt
and now you're not hurt anymore or you
know we've solved this let's show some
community now you know it's like I don't
know guys I'm just this just really
frustrated me because this is a thing
that yet we have to deal with with
comedy like it's so I mean I think
comics are like a little scare to like
try to push the envelope because now
everything is out there it's so
accessible and people can grab it and
like really go over it with a fine-tooth
comb like oh you're yep there it is line
12 you it's a vaguely racist comment so
that means you're racist or it's you
said something about gay people so that
means you hate gays or whatever whatever
how people want to translate whatever
they want to translate so I just think
hey let's take a step back and just like
let's take a step back and let's talk
let's have a conversation and let's come
to let's come to an understanding even
if it's agree to disagree let's come to
an understanding you know but here we go
I mean I just like I say I'm really glad
to have my heart made the choice that he
made I think it was cool to be like yo
I've already apologized for this if you
don't want me to do this anymore see ya
I mean that they it's just funny to me
cuz like I said I'll go back to it like
the Oscars really thought that they
really think that they're so important
that people are gonna be like oh yeah
I'm gonna go against what I believe in
to do this when the whole show
represents something that it I don't
even think it's the same as what it once
was so listen if you're out there and
you want to internet troll like I get
like like these comments I get on my
feet on my youtube channel like I get
some really stupid [ __ ] comments you
know I do I see them guys I see that I'm
like wow that was really stupid live in
their own universe like one person wrote
me said said um cuz you can do this
thing where you could set a premiere so
then like you know it'll tell people hey
this videos come in and when it's coming
somebody said oh you need to stop doing
that because I don't want to have to you
know block you block me [ __ ] by
it's like people
live in their own universe or to
somebody he'll write something about
like one person wrote about I don't like
the camera angle that you're doing in
like like hey Scorsese you can go [ __ ]
yourself too you know I mean like what
do you what like who are you coming at
me like like you're like you're like the
expert on this [ __ ] hey this is what it
is man just saying the production just
I'm not in a studio I got a freaking
GoPro in a microphone and I'm just out
here spewing my thoughts for you guys
and you know we're just having a good
time doing it you know that's why we're
doing this you know a lot of you were
like you're at work and you need
something to listen to or there's truck
drivers listening right now doing God's
work out there on the road
make sure you stay awake and thank you
for listening and you know that's all
this is man I'm not trying to win an
Emmy on this right now you know I'm not
making any money at this yet you know
I'm just out here doing it so maybe you
know in the future I'll have a better
thing this is my lamp right here y'all I
got a lamp right here I got my
floodlights in my living room I'm
standing in a corner I got picked just a
picture from I'm dying up here and
putting up here just to have little
ambience you know and I got people
hitting me up like they're like the DP
for the Godfather like no dude hey from
me to you
[ __ ] you that's what I have to say
that's how you make me feel when you
come at me about this stuff you know all
I'm doing is feeding into more truck now
it's gonna be troll city on the thing
get Q joke see this is what we do this
is what the back and forth is I get mad
about some [ __ ] you guys hear about it
and then you in the comments like hey
what's up with your camera angle that's
what's gonna be that to me can be funny
some some of you guys are funny like you
know I have about like how I'm on a TV
we be in a tiger belly then we talk
about like how I hate how people
recognize me from the tiger belly or
whatever it is right and then I have so
many comments now people like oh man
that's the guy from tiger belly like I
get it you trying to be funny I get it I
could high-five to you I get it but some
of you like you really think you're that
important you're not him listen between
the two of us of the importance you're
watching me so I don't get why you have
to like let's just make it what it is
I'm giving this to you
and you enjoy it or not enjoy it but
this thing that people have to like we
have to put in writing like I gotta put
I gotta let this guy know how I feel
about him okay if it makes you feel
better cool but ultimately whatever you
know and let's so let me take time right
now just say thank you to all the people
that leave good comments because you
guys never get talked about all we ever
talk about other trolls right all you
ever hear about trolls suck and this and
that I want to thank all the people that
leave those great comments quick episode
love you big fan love this and even the
people that give constructive criticism
the people that give like those things
like oh hey man I'd suggest you do this
or I think it would be cool if you did
this and maybe don't do that I don't
listen to those either but I appreciate
the way you coming at me with it so you
know all I'm saying is it's okay to have
conversation it really is but let's have
a proper back-and-forth and like let's
calm down on like getting on people and
trying to like remove them and ruin
their careers because you disagree with
something they said Kevin Hart also made
a good point about like all the energy
it took for people to look up these bad
tweets and look up these things about
him they should have used the same
energy to look up how he already
apologized how he already dealt with the
issue years ago you know look up that
that stuff too so I don't know man
I mean we just this is just the world we
live in now we're you know we're gonna
overreact and then we're gonna forget
about it you know it's funny like if you
look back at the Kavanaugh issue this
was so big at the time you know it was
like sexual harassment consent was a big
issue and it was a lot of believed the
accuser that was a big sentiment believe
the accuser and that was sweeping the
nation
well what happened to that well partly
what I think happened to that is two of
the women that accused him have come out
and said they were lying so then that
puts a damper on the movement but but I
still don't understand why they're still
not talking about it the guys on the
Supreme Court and like all this big
flood of news and tweets and all this
like awareness has seemed to just
dissipate it and gone away
just because he's on the Supreme Court
doesn't mean that the issue should go
away but I'm not a believe the accuser
guy I'm a take the accuser very serious
investigate what's going on as best you
can and then come to a consensus you
know
agreement ERDs and sometimes there's no
solution because the problem with like
sexual harassment for instance it's such
a private crime that's what sucks about
it you know it's like because people you
know they're not like lecture harassing
well I could put on Instagram I go this
is me touching some titties you know
these people just don't do that you know
maybe they should if they did and we
would be like got you you know but um
you know that's another example of that
it's like that's another example of like
we we jump on the issue it spreads
through social media the social justice
warriors try to change the world over
Instagram and Twitter and then when they
don't get their way they either move on
from that subject and forget about it or
you know we lose some drastic thing
happens you know so an in that situation
is like what happened with you know dr.
Ford and Kavanaugh and all that is that
is that is that still something going on
there I just don't see it in the
mainstream media anymore I hope that
there is still an investigation going on
I hope that this lady can get some
justice you know but this four hundred
page report that came out some of the
details from the reporter like very
damning looks like there's a there
there's a report that some guy was there
saying that she actually could have been
mistaken that it wasn't him but I don't
know what I don't know if that's true or
not you know the the point is that's
something that happened 30 years ago 30
years ago it's a very layered issue and
then people jumped on that issue to push
a different agenda and then when that
agenda didn't get pushed through now
that whole subject has disappeared and I
don't think that it should in the same
way that it's like if you're if you're
fighting for gay rights and you're
fighting for like so so gay people don't
feel bullied and whatnot and when
someone like Kevin Hart says something
like that and you want to jump on it to
be like yo we had to make sure then you
get to you continue with the you
continue with it you know it's not about
tearing him down it's about like oh he
they thankfully glad actually said he
shouldn't be fired or he shouldn't quit
he should still do it cuz they already
heard the apologies and all that kind of
stuff but you know this is how we are
right now we're in a frenzy we're in
like okay you know the internet got us
hyped up so now we got to get rid of
them you're gonna get rid of them and
good for Kevin Hart for being like math
I'm gonna get rid of me I don't need
this by and now everybody's like so what
I'm saying is if the subject is a
then we it should still be talked about
now it's just still be like okay this is
why words matter and you know be more
thoughtful about what you say and then
my pushback on that is just to say like
let's also remember context let's
remember subtlety and nuance let's
remember the gray area that not
everything is black and white and you
can't just take things out of context
and then and use them to like dictate
who people are right so yeah man I don't
know we just just try to communicate
with each other I really think if you're
fighting about something now you're
fighting with somebody about us
something you disagree hear the other
person be heard listen to the other
person and then you guys if you still
don't agree fine but damn we don't have
to just because we disagree you know
tear down somebody's world or or or
judge someone's character based off one
thing especially just a hundred and
forty characters on the internet now by
the way there are some people that say
some [ __ ] there you go war wall why
would you say that but I think you know
it when you see it you know what I mean
I think you know it when you see it you
know it when you hear it it you know and
I think that common sense needs to get
back into the conversation okay so I
don't know yet I'm just gonna keep
ranting on about this but that's that
that's just you know that's that's
riffing with Griffin this week you know
internet trolls and internet and and and
social justice warriors and Kevin Hart
and good for him so I'm sure he's gonna
move go on and move on to still continue
to have a very beautiful and successful
career but I commend him on making the
choice just to pull out not apologize
not to something that he's already done
okay because at some point you just
stick up for yourself and the Oscars
should have stuck up for him they should
have stepped up and said because they
already got enough issues or they're
alienating a lot of people every every
year so fix your own house before you
start throwing stones alright I think I
feel better I got that all out anyways
this is written with Griffin and I
totally appreciate you guys for
listening next week is gonna be New
Years my show comes out I believe New
Year's Eve or I don't know whatever
Monday that is that's gonna be a that's
gonna be a good one you guys look out
for that that's gonna be a good one I
have some special guests on that one but
you guys are great and thank you for
listening please spread the word tell
friends you're not gonna agree with
every episode and I'm fine with that you
can leave comments down there let me
know but I do appreciate the people that
are sticking around and thank you very
much
[Music]